In a pink helicopter, I'll fly home to you~
In a pink helicopter, yes,  then I'll fly home to you every day
In a pink helicopter, all the way home to you
yes, in a pink helicopter I'll fly through the stars to youuuu~
*watch pewds dancing*
Welcome everybody to Meme Review©
YouTube's favorite show, yes welcome welcome and finally *claps*
Finally I can learn about memes from
PewDiePie who..
What have I been doing with my life until now..
I know don't worry.
It's going to be ok you are in safe hands. I'm going to tell you all about the memes
Let's just not waste any more time and let's get into the memes *claps*
Please please Felix, tell me, what memes have you selected this week on Meme Review©. I need to know what meme
*claps*
*demonic pewds*
*To Be Continued*
*Right now*
Well the first meme is of course Savage Patrick, it's a spongebob meme which some *mumble* immediately makes me wanna gag and
Poke my eyes out, but it is actually quite good
It's a solid spongebob meme
Yes, when you secretly on birth control, and you ask him for Plan B money
Savage Patrick
My god this meme actually started as a women's movement meme for women to feel like they are also
Savage because they are whamen can be Savage yessuh when he giving you head start telling you how good you taste?
When he really he's tasting another man nut
Savage
Patrick oh, I am so pleased that finally women have a meme that they can enjoy and be all like they're
Relatable and such I'm all for the women's meme movement
there's just not enough women in the meme community scene and it makes me so proud and I
Really cannot speak loudly enough for them
When you're riding his face
and you pee a little this is actually disgusting ok I can no longer approve of this meme. When you
clapping shit from the back and her wig fall off so you put it on
wait
Absolute savage, my god. This meme plays of course on the absolute Mad Lad meme
But let's be real here, any meme really
just spawns on another meme they're all just the same memes balled together in different disguises
When you're getting a prostate exam
But your doctor doesn't know it's opposite day Wow Pewdiepie: *snot  comes out nose* edit this out
Please brad and brad #2
Brad and Brad number two great great. I'm sure they'll appreciate that one great
I can almost see what this one says that
that look when someone is tryin to roast you and you about to end his whole life in one
sentence
Absolute savage Patrick. When she's 13, but you got the stiffy, Uh?
Great it's not just savage Patrick
It's more like, taking advantage Patrick I would debate
It's probably more suiting name. When the sex is trash,
so you spit on her back and act like you nutted, so you can dip(?) clearly
This is a meme with an intellectual seal of approval. When you drink water
that's free
Savage Patrick. My god! How far can they take this meme you might say. Oh no
When people say my 3d artwork is ugly, creepy and disgusting, but that was the plan all along
oh
my god
Who made,
Who made this crying face crying face crying face emoji that is disgusting, despicable!
And I'm also
Quite aroused. I would let that Patrick Savage me if you know what I mean. Me making plans in the group chat
Knowing I'm not gonna show up anyway
How relatable and joyous wow this meme is already shit, and it has barely even gotten started
$399 everybody
Excellent I think this one is actually my favorite. Me leaving the pot in the sink because it needs to soak
Why is his eyebrows two M characters?
Let's rate this meme everybody first of all it's a spongebob meme
So we get to plus, nothing, because it's a garbage. That's right
It's trash. iT bElOnGs iN tHe TrAsH gUyS. Second of all it gets one patrick Star. That's all it gets
*claps*
Next meme everybody, next meme
Fortnite memes the best finest of all somehow
Fortnite is now the most watched and streamed game on twitch reaching twice as many viewers as PUBG
PUBG the game that started it all
But then this roblox ass looking game came out of nowhere and said hey we're free
You can play play us please and thus creating
By its popularity a lot a lot of memes . Some of them starting off with the theme of romance
Romans isn't dead i'm hiding in a bush to text you back in fortnight. Well real
epic gamer dudes like myself
Alright, we wouldn't boast about such such such acts okay
We will just do it like it was an any day sort of deed alright
I wouldn't boast about me giving flowers to my girlfriend
I just do it because I'm a gentleman and I wouldn't tell people oh yes
I am hiding it in a shack right now. Just so I can text you back, baby
I would be too good to even have to do that. I'm sending you this text in a bush
Stop crying face crying face crying face crying face crying face crying face
That is absolutely hilarious, and the funniest thing I might have seen in my entire life
Somehow the theme between fortnight and relationships continues. Her: He's probably thinking about another woman
Him: But I shot him with a pump shotgun from close range
And it only did seven damage this meme is stolen and we already reviewed it!
Somehow the relationship meme in fortnite continues
Find a girl who supports your fortnight goals I hate fortnite! Baby, you can do this
Look at your mistakes
analyse them
fix them
dominate
Solo, oh my god, baby. I'm so proud of you
sometimes I think that Stalin was right, not about the gulags, but of course about people playing fortnight
As a father. It's my job to respect my son's opinion. UM.. Dad?
Yes, my dear son? PUBG Is better than fortnite
What is this? what is this huh? wHaT iS tHis?
Are you trying to pretend that it's somehow the better opinion to prefer fortnite over PUBG
That's like saying
Roblox is better than Minecraft
Hunger Games, is
Better than Harry Potter you just cannot do that you just can't say those things
Hey kid, you should play fortnite. No Thanks. I'm already gay
Gunshots fortnite people, if you get shot in PUBG. You gotta take it like a man and realise
ptchung gotcha in fortnite you just have to build and then, I can't, I-I  never played the game actually
I don't know what happens
I guess you build stuff in the game? when Trump plays fortnite for the first time and sees that you can build walls
wow
It made a rebounce everybody look at that when ya boy is crying because his girl dumped him
And you realized he has more time to spend with you and fortnite. Oh look how cute
PUBG is better than fortnight oh, no, it's retar- no!
PUBG is better than fortnite
Just because you plebs can't afford to buy a video game doesn't make it better you dumb little
Schmucks don't make me laugh
Discussing a spot to land in fortnite Battle Royale. You are playing a kids game
You realize that with kids cartoons. this male just played fortnite, at the moment he stands no chance of mating
That's right. If you are playing fortnite you are a pathetic beta male that needs to just stop
You might as well be speedrunning Hello Kitty Island Adventure
Because that's about as pathetic as you are PUBG versus fortnite. That's right
solid evidence
I got solid proof here that real men plays PUBG
And little whiny roblox minecraft kids play fortnite. It has been proven. Hey It's the PUBG Bros
Mama, why-a you never remember my name? I am-a sorry free to play PUBG. Oh absolute savage
Whoa, the fortnite memes gets of course a nine out of
Six
Do we have time for bonus me let's investigate
Sorry we didn't have time for bonus meme, perhaps next time you will be more lucky